so oxytocin does a lot of things in our
body it makes us feel connected so when
we're making eye contact with people
when we hand shake we touch we have
moments we're like oh you do that yes i
do that too
that all produces this chemical that
makes us feel the warm and fuzzies they
found that if people do nose sprays of
oxygen like
they will participate collaborate and
give away more money in prisoner's
dilemma game oh my god there's there's a
whole market for this now
the other thing that we're looking for
is dopamine the chemical of pleasure
it's also the chemical of motivation
when we feel excited about something we
want to learn more this is why when i
answer a question that i haven't
answered before it actually gives myself
dopamine right like i get to share a
story i haven't shared so my secret push
for asking non-socially scripted
questions the secret reason i'm doing
that is not only because you might find
out something it's also to wake them up
that they might get to talk about
something that gets them a little bit
excited and that in a weird way makes
you more memorable